[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you minute alone thank you thank
you thank you thank you
thank you sit sit thank you thank you so
much thank you thank you sit sit sit
thank you I love you back I mean we
could do this the whole time I don't
give a [ __ ] I'll just stand here listen
to you sit sit
all right let's sit down let's do this
so thank you for having me I'm super
excited to be here there's a lot of
different things I want to cover I'm
super excited about the format I hear
we're gonna be doing the VIP Q&A up here
which I'm super excited about so I'm
looking forward to that part for me it's
been a pretty exciting last couple days
of touring through Asia I've given a
couple speeches and a bunch of different
themes are popping up and I think in
general I'm spending a lot of time
trying to figure out how do I bring the
most value to a conference what's going
through the mindset of the individuals
why are you even here on a Sunday
afternoon what can I bring value in a
world where so much of the content that
I'm putting out is widely free like what
what's this about obviously it's fun to
do it live and it's fun for me to visit
the region and I'm very humbled to be
here but I think for me I'm trying to
think about the take homes and it's
really interesting the I have a sneaker
coming out tomorrow in the States called
clouds and dirt it's the first video
that Dirac made for me let's hear it up
for D Rock
[Applause]
so the first video we ever made was
called clouds and dirt and the reason we
did that I think it's important because
if you think about it it's no different
than the first issue of a comic book
you're establishing the origin story and
I think when I think about my career and
more importantly let's take me out of
the equation when I look at the people
that are winning and when I say winning
I think the biggest issue we have right
now is how we define winning I think way
too many people are defining winning
based on how many followers somebody has
how much money somebody has what things
somebody has and for me I've realized as
I'm going through this process it's
unbelievable how much to me
the happiness factor factors into
winning like what am i are you happy
like you know by many standards there's
so many different people that maybe
winning or losing based on your singular
judgment but the reality is you have no
idea of what's really happening within
their mindset and what's happening in
their home you're looking at the outside
facade and I think as this world
continues to grow we've become
incredibly adapt at making us look a
certain way in our social media versus
what's really happening in our head and
that's something we've always done we've
always bought homes that were too big
cars that were too much closed that was
too much because we are unbelievably
interested in other people's opinions
about us versus our own opinions about
ourselves and so when I think about why
the first film we ever made was called
clouds and dirt it's because it's my
basic thesis in life and definitely the
reason I'm successful in business has a
lot to do with clouds and dirt because
it's about the macro and the micro it's
about the strategy the the why to me
what really makes me contemporary right
now and why this is a growing audience
and where my business
is coming from is coming from two
reasons one I'm in write about what the
world was gonna do and I map strategies
that played out that worked my macro
thesis was right it was very simple it
wasn't super complicated ten years ago I
decided that this device was way more
important than most people thought it
was and I decided whoever won on this
device whoever controlled the home
screen whether or not was email or text
messaging or social networks whoever won
that the people that won on top of that
three layers the Internet the platforms
on top of the Internet and then the
people that know how to use the
platforms on top of the Internet we're
gonna be the winners the internet was
gonna win the platform's Facebook
YouTube they were gonna win and then the
people that knew how to execute next the
vloggers the personalities and the
startups that knew how to make content
that it was a very simple thesis I
executed against it but that's only one
part of it the other part of my macro
was not just my strategy and business it
was that I figured myself out at a very
young age that the game the game itself
was what I loved it and I'll be very
frank it saddens me that so many people
in the audience's kpi
is figuring out a way to max about money
so that they can then deploy that money
to buy things that think will make them
happy the reason that makes me sad is
I've just seen it not work out time and
time again people think it's the money
that makes them happy or the thing they
can buy with the money and the reality
is it just doesn't play out and so for
me the macro was not only was I right
about where the attention of every
person was gonna end up and then execute
within it
I knew that building it and eating [ __ ]
building and eating [ __ ] was gonna make
me happy
I recognize that eating the dirt is the
thing that makes me most happy which
means I'll never be upset
everybody's in a rush you know I how
many people here raise your hands have
talked to have heard me talk about
patients raise your hands
great so I've had a very interesting
epiphany to be very frank with you I
didn't realize that I love the patients
so much and push it so much because I
loved the process of course I love
patients I never want to stop as a
matter of fact on the way here I would
say to somebody I the word I was like
I'm just for playing my business career
because I never wanted to end I always
want to work I have no interest in ever
retiring I don't want to buy a [ __ ]
Island I don't want to sell vaynermedia
right even my business goals of buying
the Jets the second I buy them it's
gonna be [ __ ] hard to win a [ __ ]
Super Bowl right I love the process
I want the process you need to figure
out what your process is because to be
successful you have to understand what's
so amazing about the Internet
why does every 15 to 20 year old want to
be an influencer because they can let me
just say it really quickly why does
every 15 to 20 year old want to be an
influencer because they can you can make
$50,000 a year you can make $100,000 a
year just being you having brands
subsidize your life or selling t-shirts
or whatever may be the reason most
teenagers in the world in the world want
to be a Kol or an influencer is because
it's practical here's the problem with
it everybody can do it it's a supply and
demand issue everybody can start an
Instagram and YouTube account tomorrow
which by virtue means everybody can
which means you're competing with
everybody which means you have to be
good this is a very important point
because the reality is
actually work hard enough to be good
enough versus the next person you're
gonna have to put in so many hours in
the game and the only way to put in the
hours to differentiate is to put in the
hours we look for so many angles I am
fascinated by how many people are
looking for the angle for did me feel
like Carrie I hear all your stuff but
like whether they meet me in a
conference like this in QA or on the
street or in a business meeting they're
like yeah yeah yeah but just give me the
one thing my friends there's no one
thing they're like but the Hat like do
you really think there's some magical
[ __ ] hashtag out there that's gonna
blow up your [ __ ] accountant like do
you really think that's how it works I'm
just completely fascinated by
everybody's lack of patience and lack of
process and so really my macro I'm
starting and this is listen I'm really
excited because I I promise you this and
you'll see in my content for the next
five to seven years I will reference
this trip and this speech because I'm
starting to realize calm down calm down
you still might [ __ ] it up so let's
relax you stop thirty five minutes and
13 seconds it's relaxed but I realize
that I'm starting to put the pieces
together that the macro is not just
having the right business strategy let
me give you a macro voice is gonna win
Alexa and Google and Apple are gonna
build voice devices everybody in this
room over the next 10 years is gonna
gravitate towards voice devices apps are
gonna be built on top of the voice
devices and the next Spotify and the
next SoundCloud and annex YouTube and
the next Facebook the next trillion
dollar companies will be Voice apps it
will be a huge industry everybody here
should go home and read ten hours a
[ __ ] week about voice apps voice
devices everybody here should go by in a
lecturer you should absolutely have one
just work with your [ __ ] Siri that
[ __ ] sucks today but gets better
voice will win I'm giving
you the macro strategy voice will win
put in the bank D rocks filming
somewhere it's done
there's plenty cameras here voice when
that's done it's gonna happen
now what everyday get emails from people
like Oh Gary this sucks like I had the
idea for uber before it happened who
gives a [ __ ] about your idea do you know
why nobody talks about copywriting and
pant and patents anymore like they used
to 15 years ago cuz they don't mean [ __ ]
the game is about execution the reason
most of you don't execute is because
other people's opinions about you matter
more than your own about yourself no
[ __ ] you can't work and put out as much
content you're worried about other
people's opinions you literally stop
posting more content on social media cuz
one random account named duty face 47
said that you were ugly or stupid and
that stopped you my friends you have to
get your macro right you have to know
where the world's going or where you
think it's going you have to know what
you can do about it cool so now I just
said the voice is gonna win what just
went through all 2,000 people's heads
did you say and take a step back I'm
gonna become an investor and I'm gonna
invest in the next Facebook or Twitter
on voice is that your move did you take
a step back and say you know what I've
been thinking about doing a podcast let
me make a voice app along with that
podcast and try to win there did you
take a step back and say you're gonna
start advertising on Voice apps when
they first come out to sell your
t-shirts or your course or your real
estate like what what what did you
decide when you heard voice was gonna
win but most of all you've got to be in
a good enough place to execute and win
and you've got to understand it's about
pattern recognition for me whether it
was baseball cards or lemonade stands or
the liquor store my career has been
basically the same if I was standing
here in 1996 when I launched
winelibrary.com
I would tell you that the internet was
gonna win for all the youngsters in here
a lot of people thought the internet was
a fad that it wasn't going to be a big
thing
next it was gonna be email then it was
gonna be Google AdWords then it was
gonna be YouTube then it was gonna be
social media it's all been the same
thing it will always be the same thing
before I was in the business world
it was television cable before that
Network television before that radio
before that newspapers this is not very
complicated this is very simple
communication is how people make
decisions you want to sell something you
need somebody's attention then you tell
them you tell them through words you
tell them through audio you tell them
through video my friends this is [ __ ]
simple this is [ __ ] simple as [ __ ]
don't get it confused this is simple as
[ __ ] the phone has one if you do not
have content on LinkedIn Facebook
Twitter YouTube you don't exist do you
understand you don't [ __ ] exist if
you're not putting out something today
somebody else is you're losing market
share I don't give a [ __ ] how much money
you're making and how good you're doing
you are not standing still
either you're moving forward and you're
moving backwards it's as simple as that
so if you're not posting five seven
fifteen thirty pieces of content a day
on these platforms you're going
backwards because tons of people are
it's that simple the question I have is
why the [ __ ] aren't you doing it how
many people here have been watching my
content for more than a year raise your
hand
Thanks the problem is if you're a
year-plus in like half this room is and
you're not posting twenty thirty pieces
of content day regardless of what your
job is regardless of what's going on
you're just hearing me you're not
executing you can read about push-ups
but if you don't do them nothing happens
and so what's really important to me is
my mainly interested in legacy and my
legacy is at the mercy of you see most
people like that you don't do anything
you know why because you keep giving
them money
most people like that you don't do
anything because you keep giving them
money the reason to keep giving the
money for courses and things of that
nature and books and events is because
it makes you feel like you're doing
something paying for information and
doing nothing with it is being a [ __ ]
sucker so it's true and so for me I'm
trying to figure out how the [ __ ] to get
you to do [ __ ] my concept of [ __ ]
pounding it in your head for free every
day seven days a week on every platform
in every format is working to some
degree the problem is it's not working
for most and so I sit here today in this
room with you desperately trying to
figure out why and every day that goes
by the more and more it's getting very
clear to me why you're not it's getting
clearer to me that you are valuing
somebody's opinion more than you're
valuing your own you actually are
worried about what your parents think
you're worried about what your siblings
think your girlfriend thinks your
buddies think the world thinks you have
allowed outside voices to be more
powerful than your own and it will
always dominate you for the rest of time
and I can give you unlimited [ __ ]
tactics I can give you the [ __ ] money
and you're gonna [ __ ] lose so please
if you allow me if it took being in
person together you have to figure out
who's voice is louder than yours and
figure out what they're up to
why are they giving you that advice a
lot of times they think they're giving
you advice that's good they think
they're doing the right thing but my
friends
this is a mental game this is a mental
warfare this is absolutely that because
the reality is actually you know what
this is a fair question and honestly
we're here so please be honest by show
of hands how many people aren't are not
in the professional place they'd like to
be raise your hands raise it hi hi
don't lie hi hi stand up stand up if
you're not in a professional place that
you want to be do it I'm gonna wait
there's nothing embarrassing I'm
standing so own it don't be full of [ __ ]
don't try to act cool because you're
sitting and it makes it look like that
you're good stand it if you are not in
the professional place that you want to
be cool everybody who's standing I have
something that you need to hear and I
need you to listen very carefully this
right now the last 10 years of the
global economy and how much money's in
it and this because of the internet and
the devices has made the last two three
four years the easiest time in the
history of business to be successful
right now we are living dead smack right
now dead smack in the easiest time in
the last three to four hundred years to
make money and be professionally happy
if your [ __ ] standing we need to
figure this the [ __ ] out because if
you're not winning right now you're in
deep [ __ ] [ __ ] when [ __ ] hits the fan
so if you were standing you need to
figure out why that is and I promise you
it is not because it's hard it's because
you haven't figured out the right macro
either your mindset of what's getting
you you can sit down thank you so much
either the mindset or what to do the
lack of self-awareness is enormous in
the system right now and so for me the
way you figure [ __ ] out the way you
figure yourself out is you try [ __ ] you
try [ __ ] I used to think it was
super basic I would stand up here over
the last second say try [ __ ] and I just
wouldn't understand why people wouldn't
and it keeps getting me back to the same
place the judgment and look I have a
very specific agenda in Asia over the
next decade it is to change the
conversation of the way kids are
parented in Asia I have one agenda there
is a global issue across the world from
the United States to Europe Australia to
South America that over indexes in Asia
which is that parents are [ __ ] up and
they're [ __ ] up because they care
about what other parents think about
their kids they want you to be a [ __ ]
lawyer and doctor
cuz that seems cool to their old friends
it is amen here's the problem you're
[ __ ] up too cuz you're taking their
money and you are acting like you're not
and so we have a very intriguing moment
in time really intriguing and I'm trying
to really hack it because here's the
part that I'm most passionate I always
say don't listen to what I'm saying
watch what I do I've been producing
content for 10 years I was unbelievably
quiet in 2014/15 2013 right building
vaynermedia I was quiet I wasn't putting
out a lot of content there was a
specific reason I wasn't passionate
about saying anything right I I did for
11 years of my career I wrote crush it I
came out as I hey this [ __ ] is really
like this you know if you go read crush
it right now it was written in 2008 it's
ridiculous how much that played out in
personal brand it's the whole book
that's why I wrote crushing it because I
was like [ __ ] it's still happening and a
lot of people are winning and it's fun
to be here I mean like one of the most
interesting things about the Philippines
is how remarkably underpriced the ads
are on YouTube and Facebook and
Instagram how many of the
they're doing incredible work here yet
there's not as much money coming into
them so you could take advantage of it
everything I believe in and you hear me
talking about is a better deal in the
Philippines than it is in the US is a
better deal in Southeast Asia there's a
reason I want to open an office in
Southeast Asia for vaynermedia it's
because it's thank you it's because it's
better here I love when people cry when
they're not in bigger markets they're
like oh you know we only have 30 million
people I only have 10 million people
really four million people I important
it's easier America's the big leagues
there's a lot of people doing it there
300 million gets spread out against a
lot of people there's more abundance in
Southeast Asia right now for this
execution than almost any other part of
the world and so to me we have a
remarkable time and the reason I want to
be out here talking about this now is
and I mean this everything I believe in
is about to go away let me explain why
I'm so passionate about this it's early
and it's underpriced think of it as real
estate beachfront property of places
that get hot are a good deal when they
first become available and over time
they get properly priced over the next
decade Facebook and Instagram ads are
gonna go from three four five six seven
dollars CPMs to twenty thirty forty
fifty dollars CPMs in the same time
people's usage is going to change
you're gonna start not converting as
well in the feed so right now I can get
in front of all of you on Facebook for
six seven and eight dollars to get in
front of a thousand of you and a hundred
of you are gonna do something with it
and literally in 48 months it's gonna
cost me fifty three dollars to get in
front of a thousand of you but only 20
of you are gonna do something with it
that is very basic math
this is historic this is exactly what
happened with google google at how many
people here we're doing Google AdWords
marketing in two thousand two three four
raise your hand remember for the six of
us that just raise their hands all of us
we [ __ ] up we should have spent more
money right every time there's a deal
you're regret not buying a lot of it
think about every good business thing
you've ever done if I take you in a time
machine and tell you what would you do
you would bomb or you would have done
more that's exactly what's happening
right now with Facebook and Instagram
and it's happening right in front of
your face and so I am desperate to talk
about it because it's right there and
it's going away quick and let me tell
you why it's gonna go away
because BMW and coca-cola and
mercedes-benz are spending their money
on dumb [ __ ] right now they're buying
television commercials they're buying
billboards they're buying print ads
they're buying banner ads on websites
[ __ ] I don't even I haven't even owned a
computer in four [ __ ] years
like banner ads on websites in a mobile
only world when they realize that and
their money goes into Facebook and
Instagram for real not the [ __ ]
money they're putting it now all these
prices will go up so I implore you I
implore you to take a step back and
understand the moment in time that we
have right now and ask yourselves why
why are you not doing more of this
single thing and the interesting thing
is I'm most worried about both the
clouds and the dirt the people that are
most winning in this room who feel who's
having the best year of their
professional career raise your hand good
you scare me even more than the people
that were [ __ ] standing the reason
you're not doing all of this as hard as
you can is cuz you are having the best
year and whatever is doing that is what
you're focused on not this ridiculously
underpricing every day I sit with
companies that say to me Gary I
get all this but we're up 9% doing
television our business is up 9% and I
look at them and I say Rick what's wrong
with 35% there are two things that are
always scary to me having way too little
and having way too much and so for me we
are clearly in a very unique time if you
are a historian about the business world
and society and this room the fact that
you're even in it on a Sunday means that
you already have the theoretical
advantage versus the masses to be opened
to execute within this my problem is I
just think 90% of you want to be here to
feel good about doing it versus actually
doing it and I'm trying to figure out
how to unwind that and figure out why
why in the world do so many people who
could easily make a couple hundred
thousand dollars a year selling t-shirts
on Facebook by just running Facebook ads
think it's smarter to buy unlimited
amounts of Bitcoin I'll tell you why
people like lottery tickets people
bought cryptocurrency at scale because
they thought it was gonna change their
lives right wasn't Bitcoin supposed to
be a hundred thousand dollars a coin
today so I'm trying to understand why
that was seductive I get how it works I
understand that makes sense to me in
desperate times the problem is we're
living in times of abundance this is
[ __ ] ridiculous abundance people
aren't willing to eat [ __ ] people aren't
willing to put in the grind work it's
sitting right there and I'm desperately
trying to figure out why you're not
doing it let me give you a couple
tactics a couple things to talk about
super interesting thing to look at how
many people are gonna be to be business
raise your hands
b2b raise it hi I'm just trying to get a
sense so I can give you some stuff okay
real quick for the b2b people it is
meaning how much LinkedIn has exploded
in being a Content play like Facebook
over the last three years I've been
doing quite well with it but in the last
six months it's gotten remarkable the
organic Reach is through the roof and if
you are in b2b here and you are not
posting one to three blogs a day you can
do written blogs I embed videos and then
transcribe them it's remarkable the ads
are not as good as Facebook because
there's a floor but if you are a
personality that cares about business or
you're in the b2b space and I would
actually argue even if you don't think
your brand or your personality belongs
and Linkedin if you would interpret it
to business people are watching it and
come from that angle and respect the
context of the room
I believe that LinkedIn right now is a
remarkable white space in marketing and
I highly recommend you know the things
that I always dream up when I aspire to
bring value to a conference is and I've
seen a lot of your faces when I
positioned that a lot of people like huh
and then she was like yay so she's
clearly killing it on [ __ ] LinkedIn
and you know my ambition is that you go
back and this puts a seed in your head
and you go and read for three to six
hours but most of all you go and do for
six months you know this reason so many
people are failing in today's new
environment is it takes work it's you
don't just run a Facebook ad and it
works you might suck at running Facebook
Ads
people are practitioners and so they're
not good at the craft I've I have spent
tens hundreds of thousands of dollars on
Facebook that did not achieve the goal
that I had for it and so there are
people in this room who've run a
thousand dollars worth of Facebook ads
it didn't work and you've decided
Facebook marketing doesn't work number
two Twitter is going through an
interesting time and a lot of people
think it has to do with Trump and this
kind of stuff and that's fine it's it's
not that what what's happening is Jack
and the original team came back 18
months ago and it's just little tweaks
little tweak here a little
week there but if you are just starting
out no matter what you're doing or if
you're in a small base the fact that you
can go to Twitter and search words and
jump into the conversation and go from
not being known at all to creating
contexts and relationships with people
in the industry or customers is
remarkable the problem is nobody wants
to do it because it's not scalable but
when you're at zero and you're trying to
establish your brand or business I think
it's remarkable to go into Twitter for
two hours a day and reply to people
talking about football or scarfs or
courses or haircuts or jam or camera
lenses or or the [ __ ] you care about to
me I don't understand why somebody's not
willing to put in the hours when they're
asking for the audacity of changing
their lives and living it on their terms
running a business or making money on
your terms that's sustainable and is a
good life is extremely rare so of course
it's gonna be super hard and Twitter
search is super hard because it takes a
lot of time but it's two things that are
super interesting me it's super works
and it's super free it's free the amount
of people that tell me gary always
talking about free why should i speak
for free why should i do this for free
and I always ask them like you people
always push me Gary you have to know
what you're worth you can't do it for
free you have to know your Worth and I'm
like but the markets telling you that
you're worth zero okay like people like
like you're only emailing me because you
haven't sold anything but you don't want
to do it for free
the market has told you you're zero
there's so many macro things [ __ ] up
right now I can't
believe it as I get older and uncover
them not wanting to work for free means
you have a big [ __ ] ego without
achieving anything there's so much
audacity there's an unbelievable lack of
humility and so to me this is a very
interesting time and I'm gonna say it
again because I like to recall it so
that you understand why my head is here
this era and by the way how many people
here consume my content raise your hand
thank you you know where I sit on this
it's only four or five things for the
people that don't let me take a step
back because I didn't see as many hands
as I need and I want to make sure I
bring you value number one you have to
figure out how you communicate to the
world are you video are you audio are
you written word everybody here if you
do not produce content for the internet
you might as well get up and leave
because that means you [ __ ] are
finished this is no longer 2007 you
can't debate this anymore if you do not
produce content for the internet you do
not exist so if you believe that were
finally accepted it how do you
communicate how do you create content to
the Internet is it written word is it
audio is it video how many of you here
listen to podcasts any of them raise
your hand raise it high I want everybody
in the front to look around raise it
high keep it high this this is a
remarkable amount of hands thank you so
much if I ask this question three years
ago 80% of the hands that are up would
be down for me podcasting is remarkable
I think more than half of this room
should have a podcast it takes no
engineers there's an app called anchor
I'm not associated with it at all but
some of you see me from on I just think
it's a good thing it's [ __ ] free you
record it on your phone as if you're on
the phone you don't need any
infrastructure no sound engineer you
press three buttons and you are in the
podcast business written word here's a
look dirty little secret and I'm
I'm being a little more tactical which
makes me happy so take advantage of it
because it's rare long-form copy on
Facebook and Instagram work post of
everybody spends so much time great
about the picture and they [ __ ] mail
in the words everybody here on Instagram
is trying to grow because it's
completely won right and everybody's
[ __ ] triple filter I mean there's
people literally spend like 12 minutes
filtering their [ __ ] photo and
there's you know and then if you're a
personal brand and a human I mean I
don't know if you guys know this the
only thing that I'm sure that Instagram
taught me is somehow every [ __ ]
person is attractive every single person
is spending so much time on the photo
and don't forget a lot of you are trying
to position yourself as a business
person so please understand that one of
the huge white spaces on Facebook and
Instagram is writing a ton of [ __ ] it
works take that with you as my fact back
to LinkedIn I don't know if you felt
this what's been really interesting
about LinkedIn and it goes against kind
of my natural state just the written
stuff and I mean like literally and you
see what I do on Instagram with the
pictures and stuff like that that works
on Instagram on LinkedIn if I put that
same picture with a quote versus just
writing the copy the copy will destroy
it on LinkedIn so these are the nuances
and the tactics that so many people ask
before the reason I don't get excited
about them is they're very easy to see I
keep telling you just watch what I'm
doing if you went to my LinkedIn and see
that there's a bunch of written copy
there I do nothing for my health I do
nothing for kicks and giggles this is
all being [ __ ] thought about I don't
do a podcast seven days a week because I
think it's funny I do it cuz it works I
do it cuz audio is important my friends
I put out a couple of months ago maybe a
year ago a strategy called the dollar
eighty strategy on linked on Instagram
what it was was go to ninety people
leave your two cents on there comments
I believe in it more not less how many
people here is anybody here verified on
Instagram anybody okay
Instagram leaving comments in
communities versus you know you go to
Instagram you search the hashtag you
search words that are associated to your
business you know your business and you
go to 80 90 different accounts that are
posting and you leave comments and you
don't leave comments like yo or thumbs
up you look what they're posting you
read it you take a minute you think and
you write something of value the biggest
problem right now is everyone's in short
term and numbers let me get to 150
accounts I'd much rather you get 219 and
read it carefully cuz you'll convert
twelve out of nineteen verses warm out
of 150 damn everybody's in with numbers
numbers numbers you know why most people
don't grow on social networks over the
last decade they care more what the
audience is doing for them than what
they're doing for the audience when you
post on Instagram you're looking for
them to give you likes the amount of
people that tell me that they're
struggling I look at it and they have
not replied to one person in the comment
section of their posts you're trying to
build a community yet you are not part
of it audacity taking things for granted
only looking at it for what's in it for
you who made you so entitled that you
think you should be an influencer or a
millionaire or successful we have way
too much entitlement way too much
laziness way too much audacity in the
system and I am passionate to get rid of
it not because I think I'm cool and I'm
scolding you I'll be very frank with you
Manila I don't give a [ __ ] if you do
anything I talk about I can't I can't go
to your house and make you but I will
not change my tune my favorite thing
that's happening right now in my
comments on YouTube and Instagram and
let
be very clear here if you want to learn
what I do if you want I read all of them
I read all my comments because that's
how I know what to do next the amount of
people that just post and leave no
engagement no reading comments is a
clear indication to why so few people
win post and leave post and leave
imagine hosting a dinner in your home
and putting down a plea and leaving the
[ __ ] house that is what 98% of you
are doing on Instagram the place you
want to win and you think following and
unfollowing or algorithm the scripts
where all this dumb [ __ ] hackers you
[ __ ] hackers I literally just said
follow and unfollow and like twelve you
just looked at the person next to you
and smile and said [ __ ] that's us I just
don't understand how you don't
understand how life works
short-term behavior with no good intent
behind it that is completely predicated
on what's in it for you has never worked
for anybody in the history of time
shortcuts
impatience and that's what got me all
the way back to the last part which is
okay this is what I've been watching for
a decade this has been my passion and
frustration for a decade I'm finally
starting to understand why this is way
deeper this is 100 percent entitlement
this is a hundred percent what's been
going on for the last twenty to forty
years with parenting this is a hundred
percent that you glamorize the products
I asked myself why don't I give a [ __ ]
about louis vuitton or supreme or
[ __ ] these watch it why don't I give
a [ __ ] because I realized subconsciously
every time I see somebody completely
being about that I know that they're not
happy
they're leveraging it to disguise
everybody's in the makeup business
everybody's full of [ __ ] [ __ ] and
that sucks
because I don't know if you heard it's
really hard to be a human being and
since you you will never do anything as
remarkable as having a life in itself I
just hate that you're pissing it away
based on trying to keep up with the
Joneses like so many of you are
depressed because when you go on your
Instagram account your friends on
vacation in Bali or like has a bottle of
champagne or like like don't you
understand that everybody's just a PR
agent of themselves on social media like
how many more times do you need to see
families posting unbelievable happy
pictures on Facebook for months and
months and years and years and then
finally there's a post that says me and
Karen have decided to split are you
watching
are you watching the single greatest
abundance opportunity in the history of
mankind is happening directly in your
face it's called the Internet it's only
about 25 years old it's happening while
you're alive not only were you lucky at
400 trillion to one to be alive you
weren't born during the Black Plague or
World War two or all the other [ __ ] that
other people were born with no you were
born during 50 years of global
prosperity and so much money in the
system it doesn't know where to put
itself that's you so if you're actually
unhappy during right now you're actually
the worst humans of all time I'm being
serious and I'm not trying to razz or
hurt feelings I'm really I I hope you
understand I know a lot of you know me I
have no interest in that I'm just trying
to ask you to [ __ ] look at life from
a different angle
you don't meet people literally go into
debt and then not like their life for
the next 20 years because they needed to
buy a house that has six rooms more than
they need because they needed to make
10 they're more successful than they are
we have to Radek 8 that guys we have to
eradicate keeping up with the Joneses
I'm gonna personally kill the Joneses
the Joneses are [ __ ] cancer like guys
everybody else sucks - please stop
living your life on somebody else's
terms because I give you and millions of
other people give you very basic
information every day that works run
Facebook ads you'll make money the
informations basic is [ __ ] what's not
basic as this this is the [ __ ] thing
this is the game this is the game this
is the game and the sad truth is most
people are losing this game you guys
spend more time upgrading your phone
than you upgrade your mind please and
upgrading your mind isn't getting more
educated upgrading your mind is
understanding why you do things for whom
and how we need to take a massive
collective step back massive step back
and say what the [ __ ] are we doing here
what are you scared of why are you not
doing that scaring you who is this thing
the reality is unfortunately the thing
that scares you are usually the people
closest to you the ones that love you be
very smart about who gives you advice
and how happy they are I'm happiest [ __ ]
but if you listen to the last hour it
feels kind of Razzie and negative
meanwhile a lot of other people say they
love you and this and that but they're
miserable as [ __ ]
do not judge a book by it's cover get
more thoughtful because here's the part
that bothers me the most if you don't
figure your [ __ ] out now and execute
you're gonna be double depressed in
seven years when the opportunities are
nowhere close to as good as they are now
Manila this
our [ __ ] time please please figure it
out and get your [ __ ] into motion you
have one life to live do something about
it thank you thank you so much mr. Gary
Vaynerchuk
thank you can I please say because
ladies and gentlemen 45 minutes is not
enough with Gary Vee Chartreux please
everyone sit down we still have
something for you in the next few
minutes we are opening the floor to
something very special
all right this was supposed to be a
private session with Gary Vee but the
organizers and Gary decided to be so
generous they are going to open the Q&A
for everyone - yes very good for
everyone to listen but the people who
will get to ask questions are the people
in front VIP and solitaire you are going
to be asking your very well-thought-out
question or shitty or City okay we'll
take study questions any time we have to
like stations one on this side and the
other one on this side if you have a
smart question just queue for the Q&A
and please take note no long life
stories take care when I was a little
boy no please go straight to the
question and please you don't have to
say Gary we love you so I could follow
you no we already know that so go
straight to the question so that more
people can ask good thank you Gary
yep great my friend okay all right okay
first question I have a couple all right
um why haven't you been in a shark tank
yet cuz I said no oh they offered it to
you
sure did that's awesome why why did you
say no because I tend not to like me too
you know when I think about my brand I
like doing things where I'll get the
credit not the platform I see right so
if I was to be Shark Tank now and sure
takes an incredible show I'm a fan I
love that young kids watch it I think
it's positive I'm a big fan of shark
tank the reason I decided not to do it
is at this point it's a mature brand
right and I'm going into somebody else's
house sure and I can't like it's not
going anywhere higher it's on the
decline right so I think of shark tank
the way I think about American Idol
right what I'm spending my time on and
why I switched from CAA to William
Morris recently is while shark tank's
doing what it's doing um and it and I
think it's American Idol I'm trying to
develop something that could become like
the voice okay right like I want to make
the business show we're on the face of
that disrupts Shark Tank not be season
11 Shark Tank Gary Vee sorry couple more
questions okay yeah all right
did your guessing on Joe Rogan's podcast
when you were there the first time did
it force you to get into shape no
Rogan's yeah Robinson I don't know if it
was a bad angle but I was already in
shape when I went on that show no I got
into shape because it's a good idea
literally what's really interesting is
everything I just talked about for 45
minutes is the business and mental
version of why I figured out getting
into shape I was 38 years old
and I was not in good physical shape and
I knew it was a good idea to live longer
to be in better shape but I couldn't
[ __ ] figure out the angle and
literally on a plane it hit me that I'm
not good when I'm accountable to myself
I'm great when I'm accountable to others
I like doing for others that's my
selfish move I'm a good boss I'm a good
leader I'm good with my community so I
realized if I hired somebody full-time
and that became
the team I wouldn't want to let him down
and I literally figured out my health by
doing something rogue and so know it
Brogan didn't inspire me together
alright um you predicted the fall of
Toys R Us yes how the [ __ ] did you do
that because it's the same reason that I
know that everything I just talked about
is right for 80% of this audience it's
just in the math they were not doing
anything right right they were not
winning online they were not average
they they would spend more money on
doing flyers than on social media right
and I knew that the toy business was
moving into a place of
direct-to-consumer ok if you have a
child globally you know that they live
on YouTube kids and if you look at why
slime or shopkins or any of these trends
happen that they happen at YouTube kids
and then they go direct to consumer
between people selling directly on
Instagram Walmart and Costco and Amazon
there was no place for Toys R Us sure
alright I'm gonna ask about what was
hard last question I'm gonna ask about
two people one is a foreign celebrity
one it's a local celebrity you know both
of them what was the interaction like
with the greatest Instagrammer for all
time the rock that was super fun because
the rock is so willing to still live in
the dirt even though he's floating in
the clouds at all times so it was you
know when you meet people you're always
curious how are they right are they
similar to Sam the other thing I think
the rock is ambitious as [ __ ] right and
that excites me what was the Internet
where does the interaction like with
will die so Mitch
so I loved will because will is super
humbling for me because he was so
inspired by the content that I brought
up and obviously he had a very unique
life story of like adversity that led
him to where he is today the but utter
kindness and good inside of wills body
is ridiculously inspiring and if you
don't know who he is you should really
pay attention all right well that's your
most sorry sorry I promise to give it a
round one last one last okay your most
viral post ever are these for me abut
what the one that really hit me the most
is not giving a [ __ ] about what other
people think yes
do you wanna could you say it again like
this no biggest it I think it moved a
lot of people and it was a whole [ __ ]
keynote I just gave right like and to
your point it is the answer
literally literally if you are unhappy
in this room or not as happy as you
could be it is 90% likely that you're
upset with your mom or dad when I say
don't give a [ __ ] about what people
think it's easy for you to not give a
[ __ ] about what he thinks I'm talking
about the people yes I'm talking about
the people closest to you yeah you've
got problem with the people closest to
you to get into I see the life right now
we're I don't give a [ __ ] about what my
mom my dad and my wife said I respect
them tremendously I care tremendously
but at its core it's gotten very quiet
for me which is why I'm so happy thanks
so much for coming to Manila madam thank
you so much you got it okay great hey
brother wait a year to ask you this
question thank you
I want to fast-forward 300 years from
now okay and how the world will remember
you then yes so I believe that you won't
be remembered as speaker author
entrepreneur I believe you'll be
remembered as a 21st century philosopher
yes and I just wanted my question is of
all your philosophies what do you think
will be the philosophy that will be
still talked about 300 years from now
thank you
[Applause]
probably especially how I think the next
hundred years work out yeah that
kindness and gratitude and good is
always just a little bit stronger than
fear and hate and negativity personally
I think your philosophy on parenting yes
is something that's gonna hugely impact
your generation of followers I should
hear in the Philippines thank you I
think and it's interesting cuz it's
bubbling up and I've been louder about
it I agree with you that if I had a bet
and obviously I know what's going on in
my head and my actions in the same way
that that don't give a [ __ ] or there was
a video I made about you know for 40 to
60 year olds which is like how many
people here are over 40 raise your hands
such an interesting crowd for me we're
you just we just have so much more time
right we just have so much more time
this parenting conversation is probably
gonna change the course of my life cuz
its deepest [ __ ] it's true as [ __ ] and
nobody wants to talk about it nobody
wants to talk about it and what no
question now that I'm getting closer to
talk about it I promise you I'm not in
Asia for kicks and giggles it needs to
be talked about in this region yesterday
are you doing good brother I'm gonna go
into the semantics of okay no no we're
here now if you are a director consumer
beauty brand yes and you were launching
in six months yes what would be three
strategies you'd focus on are you
building on top of Shopify yes that's
good I would spend all my time and
energy on Facebook and Instagram dude
it's so black and white out if if you
were to start a direct-to-consumer
business in any category and you just
stay discipline in being a practitioner
on Facebook and Instagram you will get
it to five million dollars revenue in 20
seconds a year 18 months if your average
it's it's literally that true
it's that underpriced it's good early
google to me that's number one and when
that when that cost of advertising goes
10x you'll deal with it then where do
you shift your focus to who the [ __ ]
knows right and and it's interesting
right because you said hey I want to
talk about now cool so let's not talk
about 300 years from now let's not even
talk about 31 months from now if you're
launching shortly you've got minimum of
2 to 3 years it's gonna take too much
money too fast to actually [ __ ] with the
pricing so it's not gonna happen where
do you see Amazon sitting within that
strategy I think you should be on Amazon
as well and not fear that it
cannibalizes your margin you should use
it as a brand building exercise and you
should Amazon optimize and be very
careful to work Amazon and Shopify
carefully use Amazon
I always think [ __ ] Amazon before it
[ __ ] you right so build brand in Amazon
which means you'll do sales but when
you're engaging with those customers and
the first party data start creating
rationale for them to not be and that's
hard because Amazon's convenient as [ __ ]
but certain packs certain experiences
always find reasons to buy on you versus
there but I would be on Amazon because
Amazon's grossly underpriced as well got
it it's it's the path of the two
everyone thinks it's one or the other I
think it's both yeah influencers man
influencers are [ __ ] crazy
underpriced it's not scalable because
you have to DM them all day long but
like attractive people on Instagram is
[ __ ] money
and so what layer of influencers do you
think are still affordable all of them I
see people who are might macro
influencers who have 13 million
followers who want 50000 posts but it's
worth 3,000 and I see micro influencers
who have 4,000 followers who want $100
of posts that are worth 400 bucks and
they're both good so you think it's
still worth spending money on
influencers a hundred thousand percent
especially in the beauty supply space
yeah you got it
hey Gary how are you um I'm Shawn from
Australia fluor why thank you
first question I come into Australia
yeah I'm actually coming with the week
of October 17th and I'm gonna be
speaking in four cities and so you
probably didn't have to come here same
question so I own a few gems in
Australia and so most more content is on
Instagram
yes I want to sort of ask you what your
differences between obviously story near
the IG TV and posting just on the on
your timeline so if you're gonna post
something you on your story you're gonna
do it on your timeline to end on our
database
I would I would think about it smarter
than that I would have pillars for I you
know if you look at me right look what
I'm doing versus what you know I say if
you look what I'm doing with stories um
in stories I'm doing a lot of call to
actions a lot of swipe ups then I'm
doing a lot of things that are valuable
for people right that's where I'm doing
screensavers and different things of
that nature
IG the main platform I'm putting out
consistent content of the kind of my
when I would call my main stuff but it's
pure content there is no right hooks in
there it's all content for the masses
and IG TV we're just starting with but
we're producing original content just
for it so I would I would have a
different strategy for all three layers
because if it becomes redundant people
gonna start realizing that and tuning
out for two out of the three which is
giving away some of the tools that you
could be using and now on most more
continual is also a fitness based yes
but I wanted to I want to get a lot more
personal with with not crowd so I wanna
do more family and so that's where maybe
you do a vlog on IG TV while on the
stories and main you see where I'm going
yeah you should also be on YouTube as a
gym you should be on YouTube and as a
gym you should probably start a podcast
of going great today possible they got
it hi I'm Clara Clara is it okay to be
spiritual of course all right what's
that one thing in life that you're most
certain are the more certain of um that
doing the right thing is always the
right thing 100% I really believe in
that you know because doing the right
thing usually means you have to give up
something in the short term and that is
so difficult for many they don't want to
give up the money in the short term they
don't like feeling you know many people
here lose in life because they hate the
feeling of somebody house getting
something over on them they're incapable
of being the bigger person doing the
right thing is always the right thing
last question what makes a thought
leader a mover or a shaker for you
somebody who's talking the truth the
biggest reason I disrespect 95% of the
people that most people respect is
because I know they're not telling the
truth
[Applause]
hey Gary how are you good thank you how
are you great so a question it's so
psyched that you're here thank you for
coming to Manila I'm so happy to be here
my question is if you would live up to
100 year old which I plan on which you
plan on by the way that's very serious
back to us 40 year olds like just very
basic if you know I'm not deep in the
medical space but I've been flirting cuz
as you get older you start giving a [ __ ]
it's a layup if you're under 55 that
you're gonna live to 100 and 510 and
like pretty healthy and happy to about
95 so I'm planning on living 200 so go
ahead what you're probably gonna live to
125 oh thank you I'm not planning to
okay what advice would you give to a
hundred year old Gary Vee and vice versa
what advice with a 100 year old Gary be
give to the present Gera P so the
biggest the reason I think I'm so happy
and so much is happening with me right
now is because the way I'm wired this is
my perfect time I'm an optimist
so when you're optimistic you know it's
really just easy like I genuinely
believe everything is gonna be okay and
is good and I find the good a lot of
that has to do with having more time the
biggest fear I have is that when I get
into my 80s 90s a hundred then I'll
start becoming resentful or not as happy
because I give so much as I start
running out of time I I could
potentially regret on not taking
whatever maybe at that point I don't
feel like I got enough of so if I'm
giving right now the advice to the
hundred year old Gary it would be less
of an advice it would be me saying hey
hundred year old Gary like don't be
pissed at me but I'm doing the best that
I can right and it's a very important
point I genuinely think that people are
always trying to figure what I'm up to
and the punchline is I I'll be less good
when I get older
when time is running out I mean that
it's very I can see it I can be
self-aware I see it I hope not sometimes
why I wish for a quick sudden death in
88 so I have to go through that period
because I know that's my vulnerability
as far as the hundred year old giving me
advice I'd like to think that he'd be
looking down and saying just keep doing
exactly what you're doing thank you so
much
hi Gary how are you yeah I had three
questions short questions first question
is do you have any plan of selling your
speaker's here in the Philippines do I
have any plans on selling what your
sneakers here in the Philippines yes
thank you I don't think this one so the
low three the first two were just in the
US the oh three is far more global there
is some eight ways to get it in Asia it
is available in Australia like Monday I
find out exactly where it is but for the
OO for we think we're gonna be able to
cover the whole world and I will be in
November oh yeah that's perfect that's
perfect okay
second question yes what are you making
it up on the spot no after you know my
favorite part is you literally said you
had three questions and you don't even
have [ __ ] to know after I'm thinking
I'm thinking about how to say it okay go
ahead okay I'm second question yes to
everyone on the medical and dental field
okay um is there any way to like promote
on Facebook or Instagram without without
scaring off the customers because I
think so in our Filipino culture um if
you're if you're a parent yes you have
rowdy kids yes you usually tell them if
you don't if you don't shut up I'm gonna
bring you to the dentist or something
like that
I [ __ ] hate the dentist yeah so I get
it I'm a dentist I get it so I figure
huh absolutely you know it's really
interesting I actually think in crushing
it you know cuz I I that we actually
feature a dentist in the book if I
recall proper I think there's a huge way
to do it and the beauty of Facebook ads
is you can run them against different
demos and understand them I think you
need to put out informational content
but I think there's an absolute way I
don't think you're gonna convince kids
who are scared of the dentist to go but
I definitely think that you can win 35
to 65 with information okay thank you
last question yes I know I know you're
an immigrant I'm an immigrant yes there
used to be a time in the Philippines
where there are a lot of people coming
to the Philippines
yes greener pastures but now there's
like millions of Filipinos leaving the
Philippines yes looking for greener
pastures and of course to make money yes
to make ends meet but now there's so
much like so many job opportunities in
the e-commerce yes YouTube Facebook is
there any way to like tell the to tell
them to like hey come you can actually
come back to the Philippines because
there's so many things you can actually
earn here and wine with your family why
because they're actually there's so many
Filipinos going abroad leaving their
families
to bring money look I think sure you're
more than welcome to make videos on the
side while being a dentist and educating
people about this amazing opportunity
and running ads on Facebook in that the
interest yes there's opportunity do it
the question becomes who wants to do it
yeah do you know what I mean like for me
for some reason nobody's wanted to talk
about the truth about parenting so I was
like [ __ ] it I'll do it so the answer is
of course there's opportunity the
question is who's gonna do it and why
thank you very much
hi Carrie how are you I'm good thank you
so you've built this incredibly massive
online Empire yes do you have a system
for consistently generating viral
content
no because viral content by nature is
viral and uncontrollable I have a system
to produce consistent content with the
hope of it being viral do many people
sit around all day trying to figure out
how to make something viral yeah that's
against the definition of viral make
content make good content and then have
your moments in time do you know what I
mean
yeah and let me tell you one thing about
everybody here who's still waiting for
their first piece of viral content it's
not as exciting as you think it is it'll
do great you'll build up bigger lists
more things will happen and then two
days later you'll just beat it just a
little higher it's not this great
Nirvana that people think there is
everybody's looking for this quick thing
and that's why people love viral there's
this dream that you're gonna make some
sort of Facebook post or YouTube video
or Instagram posts and it's gonna change
your life
there's a reason lotto tickets work
people are looking for the quick fix and
it happens once every billion half a
million trillion times and then
everybody looks at that versus looking
at the truth
hippos and sharks do you know what that
means no let me tell you everybody's
scared of sharks meanwhile hippos kill
way more people than sharks right right
terrorism people super scared of
terrorism meanwhile texting and driving
will kill more people in the world this
week than terrorism well viral
everybody wants viral but what actually
works is consistent content
thank you Gary you're welcome so I have
I actually have just two questions and I
I kind of want to relate to the
Filipinos I was really glad that you
pointed out that thing we had with our
parents yes
um well most of the parents actually
yeah it's a general statement but yes
yeah and I I think there's another thing
that there's another huge factor okay
actually stops us here in the
Philippines from actually thinking or
like getting to your mindset which is
basically the where the way we rely on
the institutions year for education
couldn't agree more
entitlement yeah entitlement and so I
wanted to ask what do you think
education is what do you think education
would be at least at the most part of
the world in maybe ten years once they
start realizing the thing we have for
education yes so education super
interesting to me because education is
imperative like if you're not smart or
knowledgeable of something you can't act
on it education is remarkably important
the problem is the way education is
packaged and sold around the world is
completely [ __ ] up right like the fact
that people are still memorizing
information when I can tell you anything
at any time right here in one second is
ludicrous so instead you know
institutions government's they make a
lot of money doing education the way
they're doing it but it's not bringing
any value to the end
families of course it's a [ __ ]
business it's really I'm really pumped
you've got the education system you have
here meanwhile you're subsidizing it
yeah that's that's kind of sad
yeah and the second question is earlier
someone for you now it's something about
the future so might as well ask
something about the future okay fukken
zero are very scared because I was
reading a lot on CRISPR and genetic
engineering like eventually we can
master aging yes like 200 years yes in
one lifetime and well I asked a lot of
people about this and they were always
thinking that I can't I couldn't live
that long I think it wouldn't be right
but what do you think genetic people
people used to live to 30 and 40 yeah
yeah I mean I want to live to 900,000
yeah I'll look like [ __ ] Yoda and
keep spitting some wisdom you know yeah
I think that you know people that don't
want to link live long
most people answer that they don't want
to live longer because they're not happy
anybody who's happy wants to live
forever yeah all right I got it
check check so I meant I'm sorry I'm an
influencer I have to follow me out
engineer truth that's engineer truth
anyhow so the question is though you
mentioned that in your keynote question
yeah because I'm super interested when
somebody introduces themselves in it as
an influencer
yeah no I'm not razzing I'm not not
rising I'm actually just curious when
you say your name Flint sir how do you
define it
someone who makes a lift full-time
living from social media and so what do
you do I help people find go from a job
they hate your job that they love by
just putting out information so I
educate people on what's actually viable
what's not viable I'm a form of
mechanical engineer I don't find it
viable right
I probably help a couple hundred people
couple hundred people go from a job they
hate to getting a job in digital
marketing not doing it for their own
business but actually working at a
a marketing agency I also help people
get jobs in high-tech closing get I
steer people toward a machine learning
data science and trending of careers so
that's what I do
okay so first question is you mentioned
in your keynote I don't think followers
is the variable you know like I don't
think that's the right very the reason I
was actually just asking because I'm
trying to figure out how people are
thinking about defining it I think in
the company yeah but it's interesting
I'm with you on it like I think the
common definition of most people is you
have to have a certain amount of
followers to be an influencer but I
actually think that that's not right I
think that's what leads to people buying
followers and doing all the dumb [ __ ]
I'm just trying to think about like to
me it's semantics right like I used to
call myself a businessman now I call
myself an entrepreneur it's the same
thing he's calling himself an influencer
but he's he's he's training and selling
information like I'm just trying to
understand how it's going so go ahead
all right so my question is you
mentioned your keynote to not care about
keeping with the Joneses don't get what
the watch is I'm prepared Lambos but
I've reached a certain point with my
personal brand where I know if I have
the nice condo the nice house it's gonna
help me sell more and grow the company
so do you think it's wise for someone
like me who's an influencer to get the
nice combo like get the nice condo get
the nice Lambo so that it builds my
personal brand I mean the truth is
you're going down a path that I'm not
excited about but I don't get the judge
right like to me how you make your money
is so much more important than how much
you make right so to me what I think
you're going down a path of is by
selling a lifestyle you're going to the
week who aspire and so your
bottom-feeding
right by by virtue presenting a certain
lifestyle only for the purpose of
selling more you can have this too is
bottom feeding on the mental week for
your own personal benefit not the legacy
I want but but and I mean this I mean
this brother I don't think I get to
judge it's not what I'm interested in
doing but if you are interested in
making more money
and you feel that buying Lambos and
condos and watches and hanging out with
hot girls is a good way to do that
because you know that desperate 24 year
old dudes who want that too are gonna
give use $9,000 for this and $4,000 for
that then live your [ __ ] life I just
think that's a piece of [ __ ] life second
question in there by the way kind of
leave that's a third question
if you're not gonna build authority to
that how would you suggest one to build
authority like just proving that they
know what they're talking about through
education and that's it when you're I
would assume the right way to build
Authority is when people actually take
your course and have success their word
of mouth builds your authority I like
that one else last question is someone
in the audience asked me to come up and
ask you you said you're gonna build an
office here in Southeast Asia
do you have a timeline for that of when
you're gonna sleep we're good we're
gonna open an office in Singapore in the
first quarter of next year all right
appreciate it thank you you got a
brother hey Gary how are you hey I'm
doing good first off on they told me not
to say this but I love you Gary I love
you too so just a little bit of context
yes
I just graduated high school and
basically I said [ __ ] what my classmates
think of me and what my teacher is what
yes cousins my parents yes I just [ __ ]
college
and like so basically to the question um
so I started my first Amazon FBA brand
and I was thinking like how would you
leverage IG TV to blow up the brand like
how would you I probably wouldn't I
think the biggest thing that people fall
into a trap my my friend is when
something's new it's shiny like I've
only put out like four I buy like like
to me it's early that you know if this
was a year and a half ago you'd be
asking me about peach or you know some
other new app or remember what was it
fake vero like like you know like people
are always looking for the shiny next
thing not me because the reason I've
done well in investing is I didn't guess
on Facebook and Tumblr and Twitter it
already happened
I was just early and fast so I don't
think I would I would focus on IG
stories and IG right now especially in
the early days cuz you're not guessing
it's clearly under priced IG TV may pop
but you don't have to be first to get
the benefits of it and most likely
you'll waste time and energy waiting for
it to pop got it yeah so how would you
use Instagram because in my Amazon FBA
brand it's like you're launching product
by product right yes it's like you're
not you don't have enough content to
post consistently because it's like the
same product and like how do you think
mood well why do you even have to that
is the product moving yeah are you
running it through Max's you know
maximizing the search results and the
ads within
yeah so Facebook is what you should be
using the best compliment is Facebook
right now to Amazon in my opinion and
you look at the customers that are
buying it and by demographics similarly
and you run ads against that Thanks and
because you're 18 and Instagram is on
that pedestal this is where you have to
make sure it's not what you like it's
what your customers like yeah got it
thanks girl you got it hey hi Gary
we're unit skinny chi and let me know
you don't give a [ __ ] with my name
I don't anyway did it came to a point
your life that you already achieved your
goals and your motivations [ __ ] up and
there's nowhere to go now but you know
there's so much potential inside you and
you do nothing about it if yes what did
you do and it's not it's no but I've got
a really answer for you it's back to the
theme of this talk the reason I will
never achieve my goals is my goals are
to play the reason people achieve their
goals is cuz their goals was a number of
money if your goal is an amount of money
you've lost so the reason it's empty is
what you wanted to be a millionaire so
what happens next you're gonna make 10
million here like what a hundred million
it like it's the wrong goals my biggest
goals is to be the most impactful
entrepreneur of this generation by
bringing the most value to all the
entrepreneurs that's gonna take me my
whole life
thank you so you need to change your
goal from something that's selfish to
something that selfless because then it
will take you the rest of your life yeah
thank you second question actually my
passion is also sharing good things to
people to get out of their potential
okay and can you give me some advice
what we give away the information for
free okay thank you so much thank you so
much you're welcome if that's your
passion like give it away for free yeah
hey just quick question it's the same
question but about two different aspects
of the business that I'm doing okay so
I'm in real estate development so it's a
little less I guess scalable than your
traditional internet business yes so my
first question is do you have any
metrics just I guess business-wise said
early on when to kind of double down
refine your
business and make it better or drop the
problem with your service is completely
based on cyclical formats right you know
metrics or the macroeconomic you know oh
it's oh so it's more of like a prefab
product based construction company but I
understand what you're saying is that
yeah there's no math around that right
like no matter how unique and I'm
getting a little sense if it is you're
going to be by virtue of real estate at
the mercy of the macro market so to
second that the real answer is to not
overextend yourself in an inevitable
drop yeah that's the real answer to have
enough it's good yeah yeah you know what
the people get so caught by crypto by
startup by Silicon Valley by real estate
because when it's working it's working
so well that you get high on your own
supply and then the bottom falls out so
my big no matter how a level or awesome
what you're doing is make sure as you're
advancing that you're not doubling down
the farm every time so when it does go
to zero you have something and so I
guess it'll be a similar question but
for your team yeah I have a small team
so each person is very crucial yes so um
obviously you have a much larger
organization but for you where where do
you draw the line on finding someone
that's potential and kind of really
doubling down on them making helping
them grow making them an integral part
or where do you cut your losses and you
know bring on someone with more
experience completely completely based
on the intuition at moments of time
you're also not in control yeah you
found somebody young you build them up
and she decides you can do it herself
and she's out which happens all the time
no [ __ ] so you're you're trying to
figure something out
that isn't figure out of all perfect
thank you thank you got it
no Gary how are you I'm Ren Brennan
thank you so much for being such a good
human being
thank you more of you in the world I
have two questions the first one is as I
was listening to you I really got struck
when you talked about entitlement yes I
find myself falling into that pit a lot
yeah how can you help share like what do
you do to keep grounded in your life no
it's super tough I mean I thinking a lot
about fake environments and entitlement
to me entitlement is ok as long as
you're honest about it right like it's
okay to enjoy abundance it's ok to do
anything you want it's when you're
unhappy and you don't know why right
like what's scary about entitlement is
it takes ambition and hustle out of the
system so to me what keeps me grounded
as I've never had it and I don't aspire
to it and I despise it
so it's never you know it's never
entered but but by the way my version of
entitlement is all the success of
attention that I'm getting I basically
talked to myself everyday and remind
myself that if I die tomorrow nobody's
gonna give a [ __ ] and let me explain by
that I actually believe it here's why I
think I'm up to something good and this
is good I really do
I I think in 300 years I got a shot I
mean I mean it I really do meanwhile I
also think that prince was one of the
greatest artists of all time
right and when he died he got a nice 24
hours on social media and then a week
later nobody gave a [ __ ] like Manny
Pacquiao nice fight last night
when he when he dies they'll be a nice
day of people talking and remembering
what he did and then a month later
nobody's gonna give a [ __ ] so the reason
I don't get entitled is for all the
admiration and all the awesomeness I
just know how humans work right yes and
so it's hard for me to get entitled even
with the nice human being at scale thank
you my last question is how what would
your advice for someone like me was a
beginner who wants to start my own
podcast I really don't know anything
about it but I know that you said anchor
yeah I would just do just start making
shows and my best piece of advice is do
as many shows for the next three years
without thinking about it okay awesome
thank you
you got it hi I'm I'm both a good I'm
both a filmmaker and a social
entrepreneur okay 35 when I was 35 i
started the social entrepreneur okay
five years later I'm finally at 40 years
old and finally directing my first film
now directing the film is much more
sexier yes the social enterprise is
doing so much more good that's right
I'm Duluth I'm totally rocking this this
is this is making thing and directing
thing this is getting to be such a
burden yes but this is so good yes and
I'm in a crossroads right now because I
feel overwhelmed because you the head of
this one yes
okay can you sorry can you
you can you hire somebody for this one
can you afford that um not really
I'm having I'm it's bleeding it's
bleeding good could you this is rocking
him yeah I would go and finish this
rocking let me explain why
doing good is not binary explain if this
is becoming a burden and bleeding and
this is rocking it and this was in your
heart all along to go and do that
scratch that it should become successful
because then you'll be able to do this
again I spent the first 15 years of my
life building businesses and helping no
one I didn't make any content for the
first 15 years of my professional career
that's what gave me the ability to do
good you're gonna have to do this for
another 55 60 years go make three films
make some money rock it out enjoy get it
out of your system enjoy it and then
pick back up over here a bigger stronger
and better than ever stop judging
yourself alright they're gonna they're
gonna punch me in the face cuz I have to
catch a flight I'm gonna do speed round
for two minutes I understand you hate me
I'm sorry
let's go very fast cuz I'll feel weird
if I have to leave go fast my first
question is sure they tried to build a
business in an area that's my weakness
or should they just focus on my
strengths only strengths and my second
question is what is your deepest why the
reason why you keep doing what you're
doing because I was parented so well
that I'm so grateful and I feel guilty
I'm trying to do it for you too alright
I got two okay welcome to LinkedIn by
the way which I wondering where were you
we were so quiet in LinkedIn okay don't
worry real quick are you gonna crash
thinking I'm already crushed LinkedIn
I've been crushing it for three years
love it okay number two I have been
listening to your podcast
even when I'm running so my thing is I
told everybody I'm gonna give diary
pay up fist bump can you give this girl
some fist bump yes all right thank you
okay so I work through I work with an
engineer truth
our main platform is YouTube where we
not only educate and promote digital
training products but also we interview
people yes their work experience in
different careers and images now when we
do get into podcasting should we create
different content for podcasting
repurpose our YouTube videos do both or
something completely different what's
your suggestion I would repurpose it and
do original content look again
watch what I do my podcast is called the
gary vee audio screens
sometimes i do an original interview but
mostly i repurpose and so both can work
i mean the life insurance industry and
one of the problems we face as financial
advice or sit here in the philippines
statistically four percent are only
insured one of the reasons that i'm
thinking why it's happening is because
here in the philippines it's a culture
that filipinos think that they're always
safe in they're in good hands
which actually the the pics the
workforce of being covered of life
insurance and what do you think can
break that wall if ever content at scale
on facebook and youtube that educates
people that that's not true okay content
thank you welcome you again I'm back
good quick do you guys kill me US
economy is gonna crash soon yes we all
know that yes how you gonna take
advantage of that I've been saving lots
of money where you gonna deploy it I'm
gonna buy businesses that are sold for a
penny on the dollar online businesses
probably not I'm gonna take traditional
businesses and take them online okay
real estate no okay
hey Gary hey hey
we admire your simplicity and the grind
the dirt but then I just wanna I'm just
wondering when the you celebrate once
the right it's our up to celebrate well
I'm not I know you're not a big fan of
big brands sir I'm celebrating every
second along the way my friend
listen it's a I'm so glad you asked it
when you love your game perfectly it's
the celebration I don't have to every
celebrate I'm [ __ ] celebrating every
second that I'm operating got it
the end I gotta go love you
I gotta sign that book
[Applause]
[Applause]
for you thank you brother thank you
[Music]